Okay.
In this video will introduce another type of task which is quite useful and
popular in natural language processing.
The task is word tagging.
Okay.
So in many NLP applications or system,
it's actually going to be useful to take the raw text and actually augmented
with some additional higher level data of syntactic or semantic nature.
And,
uh,
specifically we would like to add semantic or syntactic labels to each word in
the,
in the,
in a document or in a sentence.
Um,
so this problem can be tackled using some sequential classification problem.
Uh,
and in particular we could use a conditional random fields approach,
which you've seen earlier in the course.
Um,
and then we could use a neural net to model the urinary potentials,
uh,
where the neural net would take as input a window for words and these words
would be mapped to work representations and so on.
Uh,
what will actually describe in the subsequent videos is something that's a bit
more involved,
a model that some,
a bit more complicated than that.
It's a very original model which performs really well.
It was designed by [inaudible] and Jason Weston.
In this paper.
And,
uh,
before we actually look at what this model is,
we'll first spend some time looking at different word tagging tasks that are
popular in the NLP community.
Yeah.
One of the simplest tasks,
probably four,
we're tagging is a part,
a part of speech tagging a,
so the idea here is that we want to take each word and identify what is the part
of speech category of that work.
So in other words,
is it a noun,
is it a verb,
sit in that verb,
an adjective,
and so on.
Uh,
you could determine different types of tax sets.
so different types of categories.
You might want categories that distinguished between singular and plural words
or between the tense present or past tense of verbs.
And so on.
Um,
one of the perhaps most popular tax set is the Pantry Bang,
pause,
tax set,
uh,
to get a more detailed description of what it is I encourage you to look on on,
the web.
Uh,
I won't describe it further.
It.
Usually when you get a Dataset,
you essentially have the tax set that is a defined,
uh,
by the,
either by reference to the Pantry Bank,
pass tag,
set a or will be defined for this particular data set.
But usually you don't really get a choice when you just take a data set from the
web and to train a model.
Um,
and so here we have an example where a,
for instance in this sentence,
the little yellow dog,
uh,
barked at the cat.
Well,
we've identified that Bart was a verb.
That dog is a noun,
yellow is in Niger active and so on.
Yeah.
And other were tagging.
Problem is chunking.
So the idea is to segment the sentence into phrases that have a particular
syntactic,
former,
particularly syntactic unit,
a,
uh,
particular,
phrase.
Um,
so,
uh,
for instance,
in the sentence he reckons the current account deficit,
uh,
then,
we could distinguish that we have he here,
which is a noun phrase reckons,
which is a verb frames.
So these are simple because there,
there is a segment that correspond to just an individual word,
but then we could chunk together the current account deficit as forming a
particular meaningful syntactic unit in that sentence.
And um,
so,
uh,
so it means that we have to somehow turn this problem of chunking or segmenting
the sentence into a individual word tagging problem.
And the way this is done usually is by using some sort of encoding,
identifying the beginning,
the middle,
and the end of the segments.
Uh,
so one type of encoding is the IOB s encoding.
Um,
specifically what it does is that if we have a phrase that corresponds to just a
single word,
then we'll just a prefix s dash a and then,
uh,
right before the type of phrase that we have.
So if you have a noun phrase,
then we would have s dash right in front to identify that this word constitutes
a noun phrase like,
uh,
so we have an example right here.
He is just a noun phrase.
The word itself is a noun phrase.
And now if we have multiple word phrases,
then we'll identify the beginning with B,
the end word with e in the,
uh,
in the phrase.
And,
uh,
I will use I for all of the words that fall between the beginning and DM.
So if you had the word phrase that contained forwards,
we'd have
Bvp,
Ivp,
Ivp and EVP.
And so I realizing now this isn't a beat.
It should be,
it should be a p.
Okay.
And so in our example,
the current account deficit would be,
each of its word would be labeled with
BNP,
and e and p.
And for any other words that do not fall in the category of trying to recognize
the segments that we're trying to identify in a sentence,
we will use the other label.
Oh yeah.
To identify that particular work doesn't belong to any particular phrase we're
trying to,
or segment we're trying to identify in the sentence.
Yeah.
Named entity recognition is in other type of word tagging problem.
Um,
this is also a,
uh,
a case where we might have to segments.
So we might have,
for instance,
a to identify persons are locations which would be described by more than a
single word.
So named entity recognition.
We are interested in finding whether a words in a sentence correspond to the
identification of something that's named.
So a person,
a vocation and organization.
So I have an example here,
UN officials,
uh,
each kiss probably saying that wrong,
but a heads for Baghdad.
And in this case we only have single word named entity.
Uh,
we have UN just an organizations.
We have s dash org,
uh,
eat kiss or [inaudible],
which is s dash,
uh,
per person.
And then Baghdad,
which is a location,
so as dash location.
And then all the other words are not named to.
So they're tagged with the tag.
Oh.
And finally another task,
which is a much more complicated than the previous ones,
and it's also a richer and corresponds to higher level information about words
is semantic role labeling.
So now the idea is that for the words in the sentence,
we want to identify what roles they're playing in the cemented meaning of the
sentence.
And with respect to each verb that is contained in the sentence.
So it means that if a sentence contains,
say,
two words,
then we'll have two types of segmentations.
One for each verb.
And the segmentation will identify the roles played with respect to each verb,
uh,
the roles that these other words,
our plane.
So,
so let's look at it and an example,
whether it's a single Ferb,
you wouldn't accept anything of value.
Uh,
well first we'd identified the verb or the tag fee,
and then,
um,
then we'd identified the Seminole,
the phrase in the sentence that corresponds to the actor of the verbs so far,
except it would be the acceptor.
And,
uh,
when we have labeling that is with the label ac row.
So in this case,
it's he who is accepting.
So we have a single word phrase,
a corresponding to the type a zero.
And then there's the object of the verb.
So in this case,
four,
except it's the thing that is accepted,
uh,
we'll label that as a one.
And in this case,
the thing that is accepted is anything of value.
And now it's a,
it's a phrase with three words.
We have ba one I won and he won.
And then the other tags.
So it could be,
uh,
it's accepted from what,
attributes of the,
uh,
accept action.
Uh,
there can be a verbs that influenced the mode or that correspond to negotiation
formation.
Uh,
again,
I won't go into detail of how exactly,
um,
what are the different types of roles that,
uh,
where it's can play with respect to a verb a,
but I'll let you look at the literature on Semantic relabeling to learn more
about that.
But again,
usually if we take a data set from the webs,
the words are of course already labeled for you.
And so you can just look at the categories that are in the training set to know
which categories you should be identifying.
Okay.
And,
uh,
whatever the data sets are distributed,
with we're tagging information,
the raw data usually looks like this.
It's a text file.
And,
uh,
essentially each line in the fog responds to one verse,
one word,
and all of its a tags.
So in this example we have,
and the different tags are arranged into different columns.
So for instance,
this column would be the Pos stag.
This would be chunking tags.
These would be named entity tag.
So for instance,
we only have one name,
Ntt Jupiter,
and it's,
uh,
it was,
identify as an organization.
Um,
and then,
uh,
I'm not sure exactly if that's the correct label,
but that's what is in this data.
Uh,
then,
uh,
what do we have?
Uh,
we have,
uh,
here the roles played by the other words for this verb here,
faces and then the roles played by the same words,
but with respect now to the verb explore.
Okay.
So we see now that we have tags for each verb in the sentence.
And so now what we'd like to have is an or learning algorithm to,
for instance,
and neural network learning algorithm that would take all of this data and be
able to reproduce it and produce these stacks for a new sentences.
And so that's what we'll look at at the,
uh,
in the next videos.